il faut plus rien à penser il faut obéir
ça va vous pas moi qui l'ait dit
scellier veyrenc inédit il a dit la
liberté c'est d'obéir au risque d'être
banni de la société c'est clair non la
liberté c'est d'obéir au loin au risque
d'être banni de la société bah ça
s'appelle une dictature
ah ça y est je suis désolé en
philosophie politique cela ce qui vient
il faut relire antigone c'est exactement
ça rigole et on en fait c'est la
définition la dictature quand on me dit
que ma seule liberté c'est celle de bâle
et de la fermer au risque d'être mis au
ban de la société bah ça s'appelle une
dictature appelez la comme vous voulez
mais en enfilant du meeting sous la
dictature donc voila moi je ne le but
n'est pas que je pense quoi que ce soit
on attend de moi que je devais hills où
je suis mis au banc et même pas de
problème je suis mis au ban alors à
partir de ce samedi le rappel valises ne
sera ouvert à tous les adultes des cinq
mois après leur dernière action on parle
aussi du test du test il sera valable
que 24 heures maintenant ça y est c'est
72 24 heures bon ça pour obliger les
gens à ribérac cinéma rien et ce tous
les jours donc l'avenir jouer mais non
attention le conseil d'état vous avez
dit que c'était interdit mais il fallait
surtout pas que de passes sanitaire
n'ait pour objet ou pour effet de
pousser la vaccination surtout pas qu'il
fallait effectivement que ce soit aux
strictes afin de lutter contre
l'épidémie sauf que finalement deux
puits eh ben on a découvert que ce qui
différencie la dictature de la
démocratie c'est là une notion de fins
savait que en démocratie le moyen compte
autant que la faim en dictature on se
fout de plus les moyens de le nom que la
fin on estime que la fin est bonne
points et ben je suis désolé aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai problème cette histoire de
test c'est un vrai problème qu'est ce
que ça veut dire l'histoire du test
concrètement ça veut dire que vous allez
avoir des gens qui dans les hôpitaux qui
vont voir leurs enfants parce que
maintenant on les exige aussi dans les
hôpitaux pédiatriques de manière
illégale 1 on va aller voir des enfants
toutes les 24 heures et à part se faire
tester et à quelles fins pour quoi faire
donc moi qui je peux avec ciné je me
faisais l'acccident je me faisais qu'il
allait faire bah moi rien triomphe ou en
fait vacciner moi je m'en fout en fait
vous faites je les fais pas moi
tellement fous de leur société vous avez
évolué est ce que vous vouliez pas qu'on
conçoit pas testé nous même si on était
vacciné mais
non j'ai pas eu peur je ne vous ai pas
compris un truc c'est qu'on fait je m'en
fout du moment qu'on me demandait rien
vous n'êtes pas compris voix m'a rien
demandé en venant ici m non non non non
non on m'a rien demandé en venant ici
moi j'en ai pas fait pas ça nous serve
aux autres bateaux de se faire p sinon
est ce que j'ai dit quand je suis arrivé
sur le gâteau pour finir ici on m'a
demandé mon avis mais un hasard c'est
pas possible moi maria basma possible
ces bois j'ai demandé des crédits moi
j'avais un homme a tardé puisque vous
voulais m'engager sur ce terrain-là
engageons-nous sur terra la double
erreur moi j'avais une offre si vous
voulez moi j'avais dit je veux bien me
soumettre impasse si tout le monde s'y
soumet ça a été très clair mais à partir
du moment où vous me le demandez pas
vous faites exactement ce que vous
voulez je m'en fous moi aimant et mais
comment ça je demande enfin de l'appel
péaule monument tourner rue de la
dernière fois il fallait tout ce qu'on
est radieuse dans le nez avec un ca lié
pour vous montrer en valeur négatif mais
ça vous foutez nous alors vous n'allez
pas croire que je n'aimais pas ça n'est
pas loin des leurs est exactement mais
moi c'est votre problème juste à côté
bah oui
on peut pêcher au souple est aujourd'hui
pratiqué cette forme de dictature
progrès que nous le fassions nous
l'apprennent devez vous faire plaisir
pendant que nous sommes des mets pas du
tout je n'ai pas attendu mais pas du
tout il ya quand même un pourcentage de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ont encore
peur de se faire vacciner est
effectivement même si le problème
différents
sont vaccinés se transmettent c'est bien
pour ça que vous nous décrire
demander à tout d'abord un papier devant
nous on a fait un test pc c'est parce
que je viens mais excusez moi pourquoi
il a fait ça là dans la fois fabrice et
non pas du tout cinéma ce que tu aimes
tu pas battu vous êtes vacciné
transmettre le virus il est seulement le
cas aujourd'hui alors là c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui